so I'm gonna take your certainly Watusi
Jambo Jambo Jambo Bwana he oh man gonna
examine what's gonna climb me zhudi sana
why Gani what kotti Vishwa can yet to up
without my dad alright it is the three
of my Toronto workshop I'm starting to
miss these guys I'm getting a little sad
that we're coming to an end we spent all
day and all night together for the past
two days there's been a lot of emotional
moments the first day that we had was
all about knowledge transfer answering
questions getting once in here out into
them on how to be a thought leader and
make money from it the second day was
all experiencial and you saw a lot of
different clips that people getting
emotional and sharing their opinions and
views and helping turn them into thought
leaders through practice not just
through ideas and now today the morning
we're going to be doing masterminding so
we're sitting in a circle and they're
gonna be asking me questions free throw
like whatever question that you have
give it to me I want to help the
afternoon we're gonna be doing
one-on-one interviews so I'm gonna be on
their channels on their YouTube shows on
their Instagram lives whatever they want
me and then we're gonna wrap up with a
dinner tonight and really looking
forward to seeing what comes out of
today and I hope you guys enjoy it too
[Music]
to say thank you for everything you've
done
I love it what what are we looking at
Biloxi Beach backwards there you go I
got it I gotta get I gotta get brahim to
like curl it for me
welcome good morning oh my god film this
guy right look he ripped the back of it
that's awesome
unbelievable unbelievable brahim drops
the water - off the chair look at this
okay we spent lots of time building this
set up bringing we don't need your
messing it up that's a good hug right I
don't get a little sad - right
I'm like family here with two week yeah
here you tomorrow we got it you gotta go
get the tattoos
we're gonna teach some of the silver we
get everybody over on this side I woke
up this morning feeling excited but also
sad it's like we lost a couple people
yesterday but it's also this is it this
is our last day all together it's been
amazing
it feels like it's it's normal now
waking up and spending time with you
guys and after tomorrow it's like hidden
everybody hidden I'm back so - the first
day was about knowledge transfer right
second day was about experiences today
we're gonna be doing mastermind in the
morning so this is more about you guys
ask questions I want to help you with
your business whether it's YouTube or
anything else we're gonna get as
tactical as possible I want everybody
get some air time if you have a question
in mind like bring it up because I want
to help and then the afternoon we're
doing the interview so you could pick
pick the time on the wall put your name
on it and we're going through doing
interviews but before that we're gonna
teach you something new we're gonna
teach you a secret handshake that we're
all gonna do yeah okay this is what
we're gonna do we're gonna everybody's
gonna be able to do this yeah you ready
Lilly Lilly this morning on the
escalator the way up Lilly seeker NJ
okay okay this is what we're gonna learn
[Music]
okay
you're right - right
I want to show you something this is a
preview of the blog on Tuesday or
Wednesday yeah well they just gave it to
me
you talk about being hard on my team and
like what they want yeah so this is this
is and I showed Alex by the way just
before this so here we go ready this is
a preview of the vlog that's coming up
on Tuesday or Wednesday the first seen
YouTube good cry good go and I wanna cry
yes you should cry stop stop being
embarrassed and just cry because you
have passion and you care and it's an
inspiration you don't think you don't
think people who watch this will be
inspired and say hey I can kind of
relate to that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
recording it's official we need to do
recorded first for the person we're not
going to Facebook live I'm so far
energetic maybe that's the reason why
you don't want to do Facebook live is
that you're super energetic whatever
whatever whatever you want to do is
we're gonna do you want to do a mix okay
hi okay okay okay it's not gonna go down
for me I don't you just go with it okay
adjust that there we go
Danah Donatella then that's the question
are we rolling
No Oh what have you got about two okay
who's that one
look at this getting a professional
brightening the screen huh oh yeah now
you said this look at the cameras
important yeah don't look at yourself
look at the camera one two three hi how
are you everything yes yes yes thanks
this is Miss B financial man 1 and I'm
so so super super excited like I can't
contain it I am with Evan Carmichael and
dude you are my mentor I love it I think
you're saying that for my heart she
brings the energy she brings the energy
24/7 energy with Miss B so I think
people have an unhealthy relationship
with money growing up I think for some
people money is everything yes and they
then only chased money their entire life
and they end up not doing the thing that
they should be doing because they're
they're chasing money and they ain't a
mid-level at some company instead of
actually being a genius at something
else right and I think other people grow
up thinking money is evil like money is
the root of all evil right right and
then they don't they don't they don't
earn enough money and they always put
themselves down they don't feel worthy
of charging enough money for their
products or services I don't know that
many people grow up with a healthy
viewpoint on money and so hopefully you
know watching this channel you get some
education and knowledge around them I
think it's really important to
understand that money money is important
yes money is important for everybody yes
it's not number one but it's not number
one thousand yeah we wake up every
morning right right but there's
something there has to be something if
you want the people who win the people
are the biggest and the world's more
success on any field even yeah who made
tons of money they wake up trying to
make money yeah but there's something
above it there's a purpose as a passion
as a mission above make money money
might be number two but there's got to
be something that you want to do there's
got to be something like you're not
gonna sell your soul for a bag of cash
right what would you did ask me
something that you would not do
for money right because because you have
values and you're a human being and
that's where I think a lot of people get
stuck is they feel like they're selling
their soul just because to get some
money right so I think finding the thing
that you love understanding what your
passion is you know from his be she
loves she loves she loves help it's not
even vote it's not about but it's not
even about you making money it's about
them making money right yeah that's the
mission yes that's it me because and and
why is money important because you don't
want people to have to suffer and
struggle and not be able to take care of
themselves the freedom the security the
freedom all of that stuff right and so
everything you're talking was that about
helping give them advice on how they can
make money it's not you come and say buy
my stuff I you know you got to go buy
right now right that's true so so you
keep the money the education the
financial education is massively
important and that's the mission that
you're on and I think people watching
you need to find the mission that you're
on as well so did you grow up with money
or what one listen to the parent about
you know so I grew up my parents my mom
came from Italy was an immigrant her
parents just started from basically
nothing I grew up not not poor I grew up
kind of middle-class I guess my parents
I wouldn't say struggled financially but
we they made a decision that they want
this they wanted their kids to have the
best education yeah so the money that
they have they use to send us to private
schools
yeah and that at the time you know I'm
38 years old right now so we're going
back at the time was like thirteen
fourteen fifteen thousand dollars a year
each which with in today's dollars is
you know a lot more and so all of the
money that they earned went into our
education
[Music]
that's what they really valued right and
so we would end up my parents you know
didn't drive nice cars
you know the be forever before we got
changes and the car would Clank on the
way through and I'm at these schools
where these kids have really rich people
and under 16th birthday their parents
buy them a BMW or Mercedes and I'm
waiting for my sister to pick me up and
this little Lada or like broken-down
Chrysler right and so you know I think
relative Society we were middle-class
you know well ich hoffe enough but all
the money that they made instead of put
it into whatever else vacations and
other stuff you could spend it on went
into our education and in my friends
circle I was always the the poorest
there was me and one other guy who was
like kind of in the same boat where we
like my friends the people are hung out
with they were people in my school to be
going off on these crazy vacations and
like I'm wanting to spend money every
night gonna the parties and it's like I
don't know I don't know money to do that
guys okay
all right this is the big question my 10
oh my god I won I won I say one is easy
one is easy
I believe believe is the one we believe
is the one believe my one word it's
personal for me but I think also if you
look at anybody who has success they
don't get there without believing
themselves and one of the most
frustrating things for me is watching
people who have so much talent and
ability they could do someone everybody
watching could could change their
finances if they wanted to the biggest
part is it's not about the the ideas on
how to do it the tactics you just don't
believe you can yeah and once you
believe you can you start asking how can
I change my finances then then the world
opens up then you start to change it so
there's a great quote whether you
believe you can or you can't you're
right right and and so for me that's
what I see over and over and over and I
hope people watching take that to heart
awesome all right thank you there you go
I love me they love me they love you
they love you I love it
I'm gonna take your cell you want to see
Jambo Jambo Jambo Bwana
oh man examine what's in a client mizue
D sana McGann e what kata Vishwa can yet
to talk without my Jambo Jambo
what is it what's the second I forgot
the second law Jambo Bwana and then and
he was already what do you say
now you're messy Mia that was wrong both
Jambo Bwana
habari Gani lazuli sana
like Amy McCauley Beach WA Kenya yet to
haiku now Matata
you
sorry Jenny a little story what it's
your show I went to Ontario before I
went to the other Ontario in California
then I had to come to Ontario Canada
really that's really bad guys this guy's
not really laughing at me right now
so it's our last night we finished our
session we are here about to have dinner
at a fantastic local sushi restaurant I
mixed emotions
I'm super happy at all the growth and
change and knowing that we had a major
impact and a little sad that so long I'm
gonna wake up and not see all these
beautiful people again for me it was
really a lesson of testing what you have
in here letting it come out if there's
something that you guys have in mind a
big vision that you have something
that's kind of on that to-do list the
lesson I learned today is just do it
just get it out stop waiting on your
dreams find some small way to get
started and just go go go if I didn't
start without knowing how it all worked
out if I didn't just send that email and
say hey guys I'm thinking about doing
this
I wouldn't have had a chance to meet all
these wonderful people today shared tons
of beautiful moments over the past three
days and I'm super grateful that I bet
on myself and I hope you guys did too
so thank you for the love I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love see you soon what an amazing
experience I did not think I was going
to get personally as affected as I did I
really thought her going to be much more
technical but it brought home the fact
that it does have to be personal I
completely get it now and the fact of
just being inspired by the different
team members and how each individual
team member including the camera crew
was involved in making things and making
us feel really comfortable in their
participation well I've learned so much
not about myself but my business and how
I can take it to the next level so
immediately when I hit the ground back
in the States there's gonna be some
major changes for Tam camp
like for real this will forever change
my life and this won't be the last time
I'll be meeting with mr. Carmichael I
mean evan is such a phenomenal person
not just a phenomenal business person
but just what you see is the real deal
and I cannot keep saying that more what
can I say I'm gonna change a woman
walls have been broken I feel so
motivated so inspired to go back and
just share the love that I had here just
to spread that to the women in
Mississippi who's just looking for that
little alcohol
I love the connections with with so many
people and meeting with his entire team
I feel like I connected so well not just
with Evan but with Lily with J rise well
with with Alex like like I love the
entire team of believe ah I can it
shines through so much with everybody I
love that we all basically cut of the
the same cloth that we're all like
they're learning putting stuff together
I love the relaxed atmosphere I love the
impromptu like kinda like getting up
like doing the different dance moves
it's also a lot like guys I have two
left feet but so encouraging to be able
to do stuff like that
yeah like the the whole experience was
incredible coming in I wasn't really
sure what to expect I knew that it was
gonna be motivational and uplifting when
I I think I quickly found out that it
was much much more than that they I mean
he Devin tricked us into thinking we're
gonna get some like you know secret or
some hack to this to this world of
social media and messaging and but
really it was about like interpersonal
like reaching in finding out like what
your true purposes telling you that look
you have the answer to the world's
problems you just have to figure out how
to convey that to your to your customer
and that was so powerful to me
the message driven by the emotion and I
really changed things for me I'm going
back to the floor to completely change
with a completely different perspective
some very eye-opening days here in
Toronto was awesome awesome because I've
been working in marketing for a long
while but you know sometimes they lose
track of the things how or how the
things evolve and how things are done
these days and to me it was really
recent ring my mind about what's wrong
or what's good what's wrong and I
learned so many things about how to
position my business I learned so many
things how to position myself and also
how to attract you new customers former
for my for my products for my projects
and it was yeah one of the best three
days that I ever had one of the best
trainings if not the best training and
the most valuable training for me moving
forward and also trying to grow my
business in my last three days at the
Evan Carmichael event here in Toronto
for a lot of fun they were very
informative I met a lot of great people
learned a lot of new stuff and I hope I
can carry a lot of this into the future
into my career and
I think I've learned a lot I think I've
grown and hopefully I can remember this
chapter in my life as being a turning
point and to something better and I can
tell you guys it was awesome three days
defense I mean one of the things I came
here honestly thinking I'm going to be
learning the technique called part of
recording and YouTube and all that stuff
but it ended up to be more than what I
expected
so this was a grateful event I my
favorite moment was actually having ever
sing with it that was awesome
everybody I've met you have been
processing you and honestly everybody
who came to this event is going to be
very grateful if you tell yourself a
story long enough you start to believe
it don't you believe it you act like I
am Tulsa what a wail out of a handcuffed
lightning though Thunder in jail now you
know I'm bad over the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access